recherche mis sur 'pause' suivi de
patients suspendu ressources détourner
la pandémie kovy de 19 a fait mal à la
recherche sur le vih ainsi qu'à la
prévention de nouvelles infections
conséquence l'onu rapporte 1.5 million
de nouveaux cas de vih pour 2021 soit +
2 millions de plus que les objectifs
mondiaux et on a perdu probablement cinq
à dix ans en termes de prévention de
nouvelles infections juste à cause de
deux années de vide c'est évidemment
l'accès aux traitements qui est un
problème et c'est aussi le moins de
dépistage et quand on dépiste - il ya
plus de transmission c'est dans les pays
d'asie du pacifique région la plus
peuplée de la planète où la
recrudescence du vih est la plus
importante dans le monde et depuis
plusieurs années les pays d'europe de
l'est d'asie centrale du moyen orient
d'afrique du nord ainsi que de
l'amérique latine connaissent aussi une
hausse des infections al'inverse les
nouvelles infections sont en baisse en
afrique occidentale et centrale ainsi
que dans les caraïbes wally je faisais
fine à bout kényan est intervenante
auprès de jeunes séropositifs en ouganda
durant le confinement l'absence de
soutien en personne a poussé de nombreux
patients à arrêter la prise de
médication barazani parc cela a un
impact sur l'efficacité du traitement
même une fois qu'il reprenne la
médication explique-t-elle
la recherche sur le vaccin contre la
copie de 19 a tout de même eu un effet
bénéfique sur la recherche sur le vih
qui a déjà des études en cours qui
utilise la technologie de la rn messager
et la compagnie moderna et ont commencé
à vacciner des sujets bien portants avec
ce vaccin en mettant du vih et padduc au
vide et on est en train de mesurer leur
réponse immunitaire la guérison d'au
moins quatre patients séropositifs donne
aussi espoir ces personnes qui ont reçu
une transplantation de moelle osseuse
pour traiter un cancer ont du même coup
guérite vih les cellules transplantées
comporter une mutation les rendant
résistantes au virus ya des moyens
actuellement génétique par thérapie
génique par d'autres types de thérapies
de d'essayer de me mais ce qui est fait
chez ces patients par des approches qui
sont moins dangereuses le nerf de la
guerre le financement de la recherche
financement qui est quatre à cinq fois
moins élevé père capita au canada qu'aux
états unis selon les organisateurs de la
conférence ici valérie michaela bayne
radio canada montréal